[Aplausos]
[Música]
las dos juntas
i
fue la graduación del santo las demás
por alguna extraña razón pueden
desapareciendo de nichos como
completando nos del todo
para los que no han visto conocido el
caso de la desaparición de mis hermanos
un caso que marcó a todo un país
santiago de 17 y andrés de 14 años que
desaparecieron en manos de la policía
hace 31 años y que íbamos a pensar que
en esta plaza grande donde se tomaron
una fotografía alguna vez felices fuera
la plaza que se convertiría en la plaza
de la lucha en la plaza de la memoria en
la plaza del reclamo constante diario de
una familia por encontrar la verdad no
absoluta de que pasó con santiago y
andrés
y esos fueron los últimos 10 segundos
que me quedaron de mis hermanos en
movimiento
con qué imágenes se quedan ustedes
cuál es la memoria que tienen ustedes
qué es lo último con lo que se quedaron
cuando salieron hoy de casa
que se acuerda
a veces vamos por la vida simplemente
seguimos sin ejercitar esa memoria
constante esa memoria valiosa ese pensar
que quizá es la última vez que yo tenga
esa imagen cuando salí de mi casa o es
la última vez que voy a ver a mis
hermanos
jugando o una niña irreverente que era
completamente contestona no es cierto
bailando con beijing de que te acuerdas
eso se te quede en el olvido hasta que
esas memorias que parecen tan facturas
inútiles se convierten en las únicas se
convierten en lo importante se convierte
en quizás en el alimento en el motor de
vida en algo para no morir de tristeza o
de olvido lo cierto nuestra vida cambio
efectivamente 180 grados y nos tocó a
nosotros la tarea de ser ejercitadores
diarios de la memoria y de la memoria
histórica y de recordarle a un país
estas memorias
[Música]
porque esos somos lamentablemente y no
sólo aquí en otros países todos los días
somos un país de olvido somos un país
presa fases de ese olvido un país que
prefiere olvidar un país que no prefiere
prefieren no verse en ese espejo sucio a
veces borroso es mejor darle la espalda
a esas memorias feas que uno no tiene
cierto pero con este darle la espalda a
esas memorias seas uno no resuelve
absolutamente nada quizás se agrave ese
problema y no resolvemos nada como país
somos un país que le hemos echado muchas
veces tierra a nuestra historia es más
fácil no es cierto es más fácil el
olvido es mejor decir esto ya pasó o
como no me pasó a mí entonces no ha
pasado nada no es más fácil no
acordarnos de miles de cosas graves que
han pasado en este país
asesinatos de miles de campesinos en
astra asesinatos de estudiantes en
guayaquil no sé si ustedes han oído de
astra por ejemplo no es cierto unos
dicen astra que es eso no por qué por
qué no nos enseñaron a recordar que creo
que es un principio básico que debe
haber en toda escuela en todo colegio en
toda universidad
deberíamos ser ejercitadores de memoria
todo el tiempo no de aquellos pacientes
por ejemplo que fueron infectados con
sida pacientes de diálisis y qué pasó
con eso quedó en el olvido y que
resolvimos nada porque preferimos
olvidar y así como país como
generaciones como ciudadanos como
ecuatorianos no vamos a resolver nada
vamos a tener un país estancado y que
posiblemente vuelva a cometer esas
mismas tragedias a repetir esas mismas
historias entonces yo siempre les digo
que es mejor caminar hacia adelante si
hacia el futuro es el futuro que a
ustedes les gusta tanto pero con la
historia y la memoria por delante
siempre delante de mis ojos tiene que
estar esa memoria tiene que estar esa
historia tiene que estar eso de qué pasó
por qué pasó y por qué es importante y
fundamental no olvidar
debemos dejar de ser el país que tiene
miedo a enfrentar
ese fue el camino que elegimos nosotros
como familia no es cierto
el camino para combatir el dolor fue el
de la lucha fue el de recordar fue el de
no olvidar jamás lo que sucedió ni qué
pasó con salte hoy en día andrés y 31
años después nosotros seguimos
repitiendo y contando esta historia
donde sea que tenga que contarla sí
porque una cosa es estancarse en el
dolor cierto me quedo en una esquina me
siento en ese dolor me estanco y no hice
nada no logré nada lo cierto quizás ese
dolor sea grave ese problema no cambio
quizás creció porque no hice nada y otra
cosa es enfrentar ese dolor es decir
transitar por el dolor el dolor es
inevitable y todos lo hemos vivido igual
que la alegría
yo no les digo quédense en el dolor si
no transiten por él y con un propósito
no es cierto
lo que les dije huir del dolor no
resuelve nada
quizás lo agrava es más importante cómo
transformar ese dolor ese dolor en una
creación en un libro en una lucha en una
obra en algo que entregue a la sociedad
algo más y que deje una memoria por
ejemplo
yo siempre he dicho
qué
aquel que hace cosas o cierto o si haces
cosas cosas pasan
y si no haces nada nada pasa
si de eso se trata
poco a poco milímetro a milímetro esto
ha sido una guerra por ejemplo de david
contra goliat y nosotros todavía no
encontramos a santiago y andra
decidieron entonces más logrado nada
hemos logrado cambiar un país en muchos
sentidos y su memoria y que otros
jóvenes se hayan salvado y que quizás
son sus papás los que se salvaron y que
ustedes están aquí bueno
[Música]
la memoria la memoria es una decisión
diaria si yo no decide cuánto luchar
también por ese objetivo por esa pasión
hay unos que luchan un día y son buenos
hay otros que luchan dos días una semana
y son mejores y hay unos que luchan toda
la vida esos son los imprescindibles
dice vertebre
y nosotros nos acogimos a esta decisión
nosotros decidimos que esta lucha si
tenía que ser toda la vida iba a ser
toda la vida
pero no nos íbamos a quedar ni un minuto
callados hasta no saber qué sucedió con
santiago y andrés hasta ver qué pasó ahí
hasta verles ojalá algún día una digna
sepultura porque eran vidas eran sueños
eran metas eran objetivos como todos los
que están ahorita aquí ustedes y como
nosotros podemos construir un país a
través de la memoria es decisión suya
diaria ustedes no tienen que ostentar
grandes cargos no tienen que ser
políticos no tienen que ser personas
importantes o sea si no no hago nada no
en sus propios espacios en su propio
metro cuadrado en las propias cosas a
las que ustedes se dedican día a día
ustedes son generadores de memoria y
cambio todos somos capaces de ello todos
ustedes son semillas de memoria y así
seguimos nosotros
le digo si antes cuando estaban vivos
santiago y andrés los llamábamos
santísimo
ahora que siguen desaparecidos los
amamos mucho más
y esta es la manera de decirles
recordándoles recordando los todos los
días no olvidando los mi papá se
despierta y siempre dice a ver que hice
hoy por mis hijos
y si no hizo algo no puede dormir bien
siempre hay que hacer algo y él lo hace
en algo cualquier diligencia
seguimos llamada la fiscalía al fiscal
al otro contactos eso no para no para
pero el amor no para
el amor es eterno hay cosas que se
desvanecen y que son fáciles de que se
diluyan como el odio como la miseria
humana como el rencor el amor no el amor
es eterno el amor es del motor
[Música]
de todo ser humano
es el motor que nos mueve que nos tiene
aquí todavía respirando
[Música]
ahora
desde hace 19 años todos los miércoles
vengo hace 19 años
la reclama del comunismo de donde
proviene
la policía los formatos los desapareció
los tiró a una laguna nos llamó
[Música]
él tenía 14 y él tenía 17
serán chicos niños todavía
casi de todo
de 17 años
y ahora
una hora del día 37 por máquina murió
fue
lo mataron y lo desaparecieron
[Música]
y el 34
a 15
como soy vivir con lo peor
peor dolor peor tragedia nacimos con
toda la ilusión de la vida y la razón de
vivir y existir
así que pides de los policías que son
malos malos
es una persona
[Música]
esa
esa es
la última escena de este documental un
documental bien largo fue difícil de
hacer algo más corto por la magnitud de
la historia y de todo lo que envolvía
pero esa es la última escena y creo que
resume todo porque es este niño
que no sabe nada de esa historia un niño
inocente con toda esa mirada y con toda
esa capacidad de querer entender lo
inentendible porque cosas inentendibles
siempre en esta vida entonces un niño no
entiende que es una desaparición como
puede ser están o no están pero ya
tienen 37 tuvieron tuvieron pero
tuvieron no tenía es eso porque es es la
cerrazón es el sinsentido
lo que ocurrió en esta historia y en
muchas historias que hemos atravesado
como país pero sin sentido y le intentas
dar sentido e intentas transformar en
ese dolor en algo más que es memoria y
lucha y como digo algo hicimos porque
ese niño ya comprendió esa historia y
ese niño es una nueva semilla de memoria
ese niño se llevó esa historia hasta
luego con su no cierto balón citó en la
mano y se fue mascando esa historia y se
la va a contar a alguien más a su
compañerito a su amigo del de la del
barrio a su mamá y ese a alguien le dijo
alguien más y alguien más y esto se
reprodujo por miles
entonces pensaron que
en este caso matando a santiago y andrés
todo y va a quedar ahí lo que hicieron
fue multiplicarlo por miles esta memoria
se multiplicó y ellos están vivos más
vivos que nunca
eternamente no olvidar ya genera cambios
no olvidar y dejar la comodidad
porque ahora estas redes sociales que
nos sirven de tanto que nos sentimos tan
guapos tan importantes y que nuestra voz
al fin se escucha también llega a ser
quizás a veces una caja de resonancia
que no llega nada no tú ves las
historias ahora por facebook y por
instagram que yo no tengo instagram pero
bueno por facebook por twitter hay le
puse un like que solidarios hoy ya hice
un cambio que cool y me toma una seria y
capaz es mejor no cierto like ya hice un
retweet que bestia que reivindicación
que cambio
o sea las redes sociales generan opinión
y son buenas pero no son suficientes no
podemos ser solidarios de redes sociales
no podemos ser o generar cambios solo
dando un clic desde la comodidad de mi
hogar acostadito en la cama bien
caliente y luego poniendo netflix cierto
ya hice algo no no no hay que embarrarse
hay que meterse hay que estar hay que
salir a la calle hay que tomarse esos
espacios
esa voz esa calle esa gente porque
seguimos siendo esto gente
de células de miles de de sangre que
corre por las venas no podemos
simplemente estar detrás de una pantalla
como autómatas que nada nos aceptan hay
que estar
hay que ser hay que ver a la gente
y por eso les invito ahorita a
a mirar al de al lado a la persona que
tienen ahorita al lado quizás algunos no
se conocen pero otros y son mejores
amigos son familia son hermanos
son amigos importante no olvidar no
olvidar a quien tenemos siempre a
nuestro lado no olvidar al que está
contigo
no olvidar esas imágenes que puede ser
que las tengas por última vez y que no
las vuelvas a poder vivir de nuevo nunca
olvidar y la memoria empieza por eso
empieza
por una familia por su familia
y luego se traslada a todo un país esos
somos nosotros una gran familia un gran
país
muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]